[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
waiting around
[Music]
and move to myself
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola With Me George Lopez
new sports sport
you know George's oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Roper George Lopez oh my God omg
omg
oh my God
oh that's on that side
oh God all right we could all be friends
let's get on the scales yep
no
Chris right here yeah man no [ __ ] yeah
bro wow
hi Gil pleasure to meet you meet you
nice looking hat brother yeah I knew a
kid in the [ __ ] third grade that had
a beard like that this guy this guy
Enrique man his dad on the Texaco that
[ __ ] had a beard he was a grown
he was already changing oil and [ __ ] in
third grade my nephew was a wiser he had
the same thing young kid had a beard
[ __ ] one day for his birthday he's a
teenager he [ __ ] shaved the [ __ ]
shaved his mustache off put in an
envelope and he gave it to me for my
birthday he says here on maybe this will
help you girl because I couldn't grow
[ __ ] I'm the same way now I'm 72 years
old
that guy is [ __ ] bald I got here I
got here man what happened last last
best that's it that's it do you think
you guys would be as excited to live if
you didn't have hair
like I got good hair I'm telling you
okay and I'm from the 70s and all the
dudes had 70s hair
big hair and all those guys are all
pelones or they look like little kind of
uh baby elephant hair you know one here
and then one over there you go just kind
of like that and I still have all this
but not I'm saying I know those guys
that
don't have hair I don't think life would
be worth living man if I was alone or
receiving anything yeah straight then
you lose hair earlier so that's why I
stay bulk I don't want to lose my hair
that's the only reason I keep it on yeah
I didn't know that you have hair right I
don't know if there's any science to
that happening yeah there you go you
know it gets flattened when I wear my
hat all the time you know they said
Don't wear hats because then you're
going to start getting the receding you
know and start playing baseball I always
kept don't worry is that true that's
what they said the hats push your hair
down I didn't I didn't wear hats uh I
very seldom or hats the first hat that
you gave me I started wearing that one
it was similar different color
and I really liked it so I've got about
six or eight of them I got a bunch of
Base baseball capsules Dodgers [ __ ] and
all that but I never would wear them I
didn't want to mess up my hair but this
one they're comfortable you know now I'm
getting older and easy to wear no I like
those I can never wear those hats yeah
and I got in a fight with a girl one
time and she told me I don't know why
you wear a hat you look [ __ ] stupid
in them
and every time
no it looks good yeah it was a Vibe
going on
like oh my God how they leave you with
one [ __ ] thing to do your whole you
remember your whole life
yeah I love it this is good [ __ ] dude
that's what's up oh one of the jokes
they said is uh the guy says to his wife
tell me something that's gonna make me
happy and sad and uh she goes of all
your friends you have the biggest dick
[Laughter]
S
I wouldn't kiss I would [ __ ] couldn't
tell a joke to save his life bro he
[ __ ] butchered it he goes what's up
what's up
kid in that I got some stories about
that guy I was actually assigned to him
I worked for over a year that
[ __ ] was crazy about him even
when he's wrong he's right you know what
I mean right you can't you can't win an
argue him argument with him here's how
he would get he get real fifth grader
like if you knew you were right about
something he'd say says who says you and
then how do you respond to that I mean
it's Gene [ __ ] how did you how
did you how did you meet him long story
short he had had a label called Simmons
records and his mandate was to uh that's
a pretty good name though his mandate
was to to sign bands only out of Canada
I was managing an act at the time that
had two band members in Canada called
gravity I'm in Austin Texas you needed
two-thirds to be considered a Canadian
band so that last guy out uh so yeah we
ended up working with him for about a
year
um and just what an experience I will
say this man say what you want about the
guy but he's a [ __ ] marketing genius
you know obviously like dude they kiss
they got kissed condoms kiss coffins his
old slogans will get you coming we'll
get you going
so I mean you gotta you gotta take your
head off to that man but the guy our
conversations man sometimes we're like
just bizarre you know what I mean
because he's still living in that 30
year old mindset like he's trying to put
paint one of our guys face and I'm like
look that worked for kiss but it didn't
work it doesn't work today it is one of
the guys faces hold still you know what
I mean and and this whole thing about
not having friends or whatever there's
actually some truth to that he doesn't
have any friends right he doesn't have
any friends man it's crazy
um [ __ ] he's he titled his solo record
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know when you when you go they take
your money the government takes it and
then whoever is around you takes it and
all the time that you didn't take
vacation because you said a day without
the vacations a day losing money yeah is
you're gone yeah and then you lived your
life in high heels the Jewish dude with
makeup on
65 years still doing it
Santana's uh I wouldn't say with
Santana's hash guy but a guy that I met
uh with Carlos uh gave me some hash and
and in San Jose and on Monday when I got
home
I tried a little bit I had a day off I
said I'm gonna try a little bit man I
was [ __ ] up
for 36 hours nobody has that I was
sitting in my room and I caught myself
doing this
just for 36 hours and then I put on
YouTube and I'm watching kiss because
I'm a fan of kiss and dogs on me I've
been following two Jewish dudes in heels
and makeup since 1976 yeah it looks so
bizarre
yeah that I've been I put holes in my
wall and
this is a very exciting uh oh and I Got
High
um Andy Bargas singer Sensational yeah
lead singer for Carlos Santana has been
at the House of Blues been all over the
world will you introduce our Our Guest
today Andrew yes yes today uh I'm very
grateful to be here I'm grateful to have
Chris Bettis
the famous you know glad to be here
amazing person uh Chris Bettis uh we
just signed Chris to my Las Palapas
records with his uh
um Everybody check it out it's an
amazing amazing song uh it's you know
Chris's story and his manager John Gomez
I'm both visiting from Austin and uh
Chris from San Antonio yeah yeah good to
be here man thanks for having me yeah we
we had a we had a great uh roll out and
uh you know we have a Spanish version to
pushing ahead coming out yes really
excited about that
um and uh you know this is just the
beginning of our relationship uh you
know right now
um there's some let me ask you another
question music
we already covered hair but is life
worth living as a musician if you're not
doing coke
I mean is that enough like I make people
laugh but I sometimes
[Music]
I mean in the old days it
I don't know who [ __ ] it up for
everybody but
those guys used to use it and they would
be in the studio yeah and they would
write stuff that the guy from Pittsburgh
was on LSD I think it's a no-hitter he
didn't even know he picture yeah
it's over but people have done some
incredible things High yeah absolutely
that altered state man there's that
euphoria that you get right before you
hit a tree I think
that was two stick shifts in that car
yeah the water was driving
I used to be my wife
it was a it was a guy dressed up like
well first of all first of all there's
nothing wrong
correct I can't even talk about a guy
with a lady
[Music]
yeah man I don't know who [ __ ] it up
but you know there's there was there's
been musicians I've known a lot of them
there's some guys that don't get high oh
yeah that that are that and they're into
it there's just this kind of thing man
because those are long look listen
coffee can do a lot but it can't do what
Coke can do no you know when you're in
there and you're drinking it said hey
man you should we call it a rap now
we're just getting started if I could go
over there and have some [ __ ] the best
part of waking up is Folgers
you know and then you're in there man
and when you think it's listen to God
Eddie Van Halen God God Rest his soul my
dude right there I'm a [ __ ] great guy
he he told me when he wrote uh
uh right now
that was that was right now that it
started with the piano yeah and I guess
musicians you guys do this when you walk
into the studio you turn everything on
from the from the minute you walk in the
door you started he started pushing
buttons and started recording in there
because there's something that you might
say
you know we always try to carry a
notepad and he just turned everything on
but he would go in there and he would be
high for days and not sleep for days and
he'd be in there and then he would sleep
for however long he needed to sleep but
then when he got up
he was like [ __ ] I think I got something
man you know yeah uh vaguely
he can kind of remember he goes back in
the studio and starts just going through
the tapes and he hears that
here's a piano yeah yeah and and when I
took him to the Laker game
we were walking to our seats in that and
that
you know curtain drops and they start to
show all the history of the Lakers on
that curtain and they start to play that
piano and he looks at me he goes hey I
wrote this
I said baby you did [ __ ] right there
he had already told me that story but
anybody that's not like at that level
like you guys already know you could
sense you can sense it there's you know
there might be the battle that wrote
Butterfly Kisses you know one [ __ ]
hit yeah the country do with that yeah
they're butterfly kisses
my daughter liked it
and then and then you know sometimes it
just goes away man it goes away but I
think music
far more than comedy or acting
is
fueled by
your passion your surroundings whatever
Studio you're in whatever people you're
with and and in the days
they were just some crazy nights man in
there right and it's always [ __ ] loud
like nobody says hey turn that down they
[ __ ] go in there turn that [ __ ] yeah
yeah because you can hear and you can
hear everything right yeah you can hear
everything and the songs they came up
with man I mean I'm a big fan of that
era of music you know the late 70s and
all that kind of stuff and the stories
I've heard and of course about Eddie and
you know the guys in Fleetwood Mac and
I'm a huge fan of all their stuff and
it's like
I mean part of it was fueled by you know
what was going on at the time it's a I
don't I mean I kind of grew up
on the edge of that into now so I have
seen the change you know what I mean
it's like yeah it's just a weird house
uh uh were your parents
um approving of your music
are you wanting to be a musician
because I said no not at all I don't
think there's a Mexican mom that said no
why don't you live here and then try to
be a musician never why would you want
why do you want a job
and just you don't [ __ ] [ __ ] up and you
know I'll pay for everything until you
write a hit yeah yeah no that's the
thing it's like that's just like the
times have changed like when I grew up
it was of course not like that it was it
was a complete uphill battle for me
right yeah but then once I did something
and I started kind of climbing the ranks
in in the Texas Music Scene then it
became cool and then like my sister
started having kids and then all her
kids were giving instruments by my mom
and my pops and I'm like what the [ __ ]
yeah you you know would not do that and
they're like well we didn't know it was
you know they had their nine to five
jobs and they knew what they knew and it
scared them but were they musical they
love music they weren't music yeah but
they loved me because you know how it's
hard to invest in something that you
can't see the future of like if you're
working a bank you go hey I could maybe
I can yeah maybe I could cudia the one
teller that's beautiful there was always
one seller that was
that's my dad right there that's my
dad's story my real dad yeah dude I love
you Dad but that's it he worked at a
bank and that was it and then you can be
like I have a friend of mine Arnold that
that motherfucker's probably worked at
the bank for 40 years
yeah and right out of high school is a
teller and now he's a bank manager but
though like you could see that but in
music
there's nothing that you can see you can
see other people do it no you're right
but there's nothing you can put your
hands on other than you believing that
you can you can exactly
you gotta feel it it's a good point dude
good point I mean to cut you up but when
you because it's all subjective right if
you look at it from like uh and it's a
business hat guy uh like a venture
capitalist type of point of view there's
it's all high risk all art it's this is
all subjective you know like you could
take a band that you might think is the
shittiest [ __ ] band in the world but
there's 500 people that think they're
the best [ __ ] thing since last break
that's right so so good point on that
and it is a gamble it always has been
for those who can like cut through like
mad respect because I mean yeah
you know you got a notebook in your
writing [ __ ] it's poetry and then it's
not it's poetry and then it's not poetry
you know it's like a detective that
that just has an instinct of of of
something you know of of uh just a it's
all Instinct you can't teach that you
can't teach that in school you know you
can't teach that an instinct of somebody
also like when we were in junior high
back in the 70s that there was music in
the schools and now there's not and
that's a part of these kids like how
many musicians of the future are we not
giving handing instruments to in seventh
grade and these dudes would be like
their [ __ ] ears would be all red
they're trying to blow into this trumpet
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing
yeah and everybody's [ __ ] around with
them you know they take the instrument
they're rubbing it on the river hey this
is your [ __ ] traffic you know don't
blow on this
[Applause]
and uh and and for real and then right
yeah I'm like were you in where yeah
were you that was my middle school band
I bought you back hey remember I rub
your fluid on my dick if I can play
Color My World
uh uh but that's where the kids that's
what you know and then in three years if
they stuck with it in ninth grade they
played and you're like okay
they can [ __ ] play you know now the
guys can play some people quit it's not
for them but also somebody might not
know that they're that they have musical
ability right yeah who put an instrument
in your hands or where did you see one
um I was 10 years old and it was
beginner band in middle school you know
it was it was a it was a big thing and
it was my mom's pushing me you know into
that and that's when I started learning
to read and write uh music and but I
started off on probably one of the
dorkiest instruments the French horn you
know which is the awkwardness it's the
one where you gotta you gotta have your
hand in the bell and it's just got all
these twisty things
you can't look cool walking home with
that case you know and I used to do that
all the time very small mouthpiece even
smaller than the trumpet very very tiny
oh yeah you played huh yeah I started at
the same time my grandson just last week
is hinting that he wants his mom to get
him a saxophone I said hey but is it
gonna start like you on the screen
right there brother you know you know
and those are the ones you want right
well normally the smaller he's a small
kid it started with an alto and out
towards soprano but you can start
teaching how to play The Tender I can
teach you how to play all those I think
it's amazing all right on you can play
woodwind too yeah wow I'm just starting
next week it was my dream when I when I
retired from the Department I wanted to
show people my culture my dream was to
walk in shock this [ __ ] out with
Mariachis
playing the guitar on not singing El Rey
I had a guitar
I can
and a very good friend of mine I'm sure
he bought all the wood Candelas from
Candelas guitars here in East L.A where
Feliciano and everybody bought their
guitars
uh he made my guitar on for me and it
says right in the oh nice and so now but
I didn't everything came on so quick I
never took lessons
starting Tuesday night
I started lessons when we get Federal
nice man good on you I'm gonna play
yeah is that the bigger guitar but in
Mariachis don't they always give the
biggest guitar to the littlest dude no
no no no
I can't hardly even see him
there's some Gordo's out there playing
that game oh um in in uh
in in learning
did it come easy to you or or what did
you you can you read music I can read
music first of all what's a percentage
of of musicians that can read music not
a lot it's all natural I Can Read 50 oh
50 that high I don't know if it's that
high dude yeah he knows I'm bad
but not on the general like normally
Pros those guys that played you know
Symphony backup and stuff like that for
movies that they all read if you could
read music you could work more because
you get hired yeah you know for
different gigs you know scores and
things like that but you know I know a
lot of players they just you know they
know courts and things like that you
know and you gotta remember we're a
garage band generation now I don't know
[ __ ] how to read music you don't even
know what the [ __ ] the notes are they
just all natural so you learn to read
with the paper and they taught you on
the board and all everything about half
note on a measure and all this yep and
how every instrument works with each
other you know it's um but you're you
know about asking me if it was hard it I
mean I guess it's like anything else you
love you if if you really love something
and you're working at it it kind of
doesn't feel like work you're just
trying to get better you know so but in
a sense and then you hated it and then
you went back to it sometimes you're
like man [ __ ] this thing yeah and then
you leave it and then you try to do
something else and then you go back to
it a lot of times now I hate it yeah
because you know I'm sitting there I'm
like when the [ __ ] did this become a job
like something I have to do and you know
a lot of people
um that have jobs would probably you
know be upset because oh you live a good
life doing music whatever but the thing
is
I would imagine I've never really had a
nine to five job but I would imagine if
you have a nine to five job and you know
what you're
what you're supposed to do in that time
and you do that the best you can you go
home and you just let it go you do it
again the next day music it never leaves
you you're always thinking about
something and you know what that's a
really that's a really really good point
is is that when you're create when
you're creating you can't turn it you
can't turn it off you can't you know the
next you know when I work during the day
you'd be working on something and you go
oh [ __ ] it's that time already and then
you just leave your [ __ ] there and in
the morning you just get back in your
chair and see where you were and just
start back again I mean that kind of
working murders I kind of felt myself
like a conductor of an orchestra because
I don't know how they do in physical
under the you know the people in the lab
you know what they're looking at
Firearms serology physical section all
that [ __ ] I don't know what they do I
don't know how to focus the camera take
the good pictures I don't know how to do
a lot of [ __ ] but I do know what you can
give me from the lab and what you can
give me from physical just like a
conductor a little more Woodwinds a
little more string percussions down a
little bit and you put it together when
you got it together then you make
beautiful music so when I know what
everybody else is doing I put it
together then we get a prosecution
so I always kind of dated like like a
conductor like music
interesting I I see it I I mean that's
that's an amazing way to look at it but
didn't didn't you guys like I think when
you said when you were um
and you're a detective that you would go
to the autopsy sure and watch yeah
because you wanted to see what
give our input to the to the pathologist
who's doing the doctors doing the
autopsy and so I can get a better idea
of what happened you know it's it's all
scientific as an example
I had a new partner female and no she
did I gotta tell you guys I do it I've
been doing it since we were in junior
high even every time somebody says I
have this woman and I always say that
every time I'm out to breakfast
I've got a 44 year old son we're out to
breakfast the other day and we're out to
breakfast with my wife right there and
he says dad there's one for George I
said what he says she's got big tits
because he already knows that's a free
and I look I said Son no they're not
those are her elbows they're not big
Peppers just like we used to see a
pregnant lady we look at each other and
go she [ __ ] yeah but anyways that's
that we were little uh
I would never disregard him a woman that
gave it to somebody else no uh but but
yeah he would go over there and uh yeah
you'd see everything and so this this
lady that doesn't know she's new to this
autopsy [ __ ] she goes over there and I
specifically told I don't want this
doctor to call me up early because he
likes to show everything likes to show
off everything he's doing I said I don't
know what he's ready to make the cuts
I'll be there but I don't need him to
drive oh wow so I get there and he he
called me over there before the ad
before the cuts so I'm looking at
another autopsy over here and my get my
partner the female she comes up and says
hey
found another crazy moon on the guy's
head I said he ain't got no graze wound
on his head
and she said oh yes he does I said no he
does just well the doctor says he knows
you're gonna argue with the doctor I
said let's go talk to the good doctor I
looked at the doc I said doc that isn't
a gray's one the guy got shot he lost
conscious he hit the accelerator hit the
telephone pole he wrecked that's the
rearview mirror that made that Jagged
cut on his forehead and he goes ah that
explains why it's jaggy you're right
it's not a crazy wound so that's why you
go give them the other half you know I
saw it I know what I'm looking at I
could tell what it was so now he changed
his opinion you know so we do that's why
we went to all of them does anybody
still do that now yeah they still go
when I first started going there they
weren't all you know now because of all
the diseases you know started a long
time ago
when I first went there you did more
[ __ ] you just went in there and you
watched yeah and you know I remember the
first time I went in there something
some guy from the corners I was eating
an apple off to the side and he looks at
me and he says it's all over your face
kid this your first one isn't it nice
yeah it is you'll get used to it
you don't need an apple by the time
before DNA you could you could throw you
could you could leave cocktail by the
dead body right now catch you why not
you could leave skin in your mouth you'd
tear our skin off early right there
right The Gallows everything there man
we're unsolved unsolved because because
now even you know guys get busted
they're like the Golden State killer
that'll make you chicken at his house
you're the glow stick killer yeah oh you
got me all right hey can I turn my
chicken down turn the chicken off
before I left the prison yeah when I
when I first got there the first several
years I wear the first five six years we
were at a 70 solve rate we were solving
like a good thing that's high but then
people start becoming more mobile things
kind of getting complicated they went
from rival gang to territorial from drug
deals to this and before chances are
whoever killed you knew you you know it
was right so it was easy things got so
goddamn well now I'd venture to say
there's somewhere if they're lucky right
around 50 percent um
yeah
uh um have you been Have you ever laid
in bed and sit and have something come
to you like oh yeah oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yes
right you guys like you guys lay in bed
and you go
wow wow that you know in my head it's
already fully finished and I've already
learned there's been times I don't get
up because I'm just too tired it's the
next day so I'll get up and amazing what
and what is that what is that I don't
know I have no idea I mean the last one
that we just put out uh pushing ahead
came to me in a dream sounding almost
exactly like it does now but in my dream
I was in a studio with Justin Timberlake
and uh then we just finished a wet
dreams
so no I mean you know sometimes it
happens like that and then and I mean
you got the fingering right but but but
but
it it when when it comes to you like
that it doesn't go away and it and comes
back it stays with you right whatever
whatever is bringing you these ideas in
your head yes um sometimes it stays
sometimes I wake up and I'm mad that I
don't remember it yeah it's gone and in
my in my I remember in my sleep I'm
tapping my foot and I hear the whole
thing and I just don't feel like getting
up and those dreams when you see
yourself in the studio is it like right
now with all of us here is it is it are
you aware it's a dream or does it feel
like it's real like sometimes there's
there's dreams that you have that could
be like this all of us right here yeah
and then you wake up and you're like oh
[ __ ] that thing was so vivid yeah no it
feels it feels real you know I mean you
feel the sound coming from the speakers
and I just hear everything and here's
another thing too that people that might
be listening that there's a stu if a
studio has
people that have gone in there and
created incredible music like that if a
musician hears about that they want to
record in that place right yeah sure
they want to record in that place for
sure in on Pico over there in West L.A
where I think La TV might be there I was
walking through there years ago and I
looked and there was all these Earth
Wind and Fire uh Gold Records on the
wall and I said um
oh what's all this and he goes oh in the
70s man they used to record in here and
they did all these they they recorded
all this here and I said I said where's
the room and the guy goes oh it's on the
end of the hall I said can I go in there
and he goes you want to go in the room
and I said yeah I want to go in the room
and he took me down open the door it was
empty and I just went in the room when I
stood in there in the middle of the room
and I thought this is where all that
[ __ ] was in here man that we that
everybody's going to be losing energy
wow it doesn't make sense it's it's for
me stuff like that is um
intimidating you know what I mean I
always ever
99 of the time I walk into a studio I'm
scared that maybe once I plug my guitar
in I'm just not gonna wow this is not
gonna happen you know and then
fortunately it always usually ends up
being you know the opposite and I come
up with something but I'm always just
like please give me something you know
what do you think that is the left and
the right brain like I have no idea the
reality and then like it's almost like
if bat if Clark Kent never turned into
[ __ ] Superman he would be the one
that walked in there and said man I
don't know if I can do this man and then
the Superman person is like [ __ ] that I
could do it right I could do it I would
actually on a heavy case like the stock
right actually go to bed with pen and
Pad right next to my bed exactly because
I'd be I'd think of something in a dream
right now let's write it down before I
forget it but I mean what is that people
it sends you the message man it sends
you whatever and and it and like however
your brain is it's like with phones you
could you got a t you maybe have a wider
coverage or [ __ ] whatever the next
one is you got more of a reach but when
whatever the universe is is sending you
a message
and it might not even mean anything
right now but then years later you're
like oh [ __ ] that's deja vu we're
talking about exactly yeah you gotta
it's it's like like you have an antenna
right and but there's something that you
need to kind of like
just adjust it to pick up the signal you
know because it's not just on all the
time and so and and when the songs do
come and it's not often when the songs
do come and you write them from
beginning to end right there in that
moment
it's just that's what you that's why you
keep doing it you keep chasing that it's
like that first hit you know you're
trying to you know one of one of the
things uh when when I was married in
2005 I was hosting I was one of the
hosts of the Emmys and and I was working
on some material on Saturday there that
means I think we're on Sunday and uh Ann
looked at my notes and she was reading
them and she goes you're not gonna do
this are you I said yeah
this is what you're gonna do tomorrow
and I said yeah no no no no no no no no
I said you know what give me the [ __ ]
papers man [ __ ] that get here go
downstairs because it was and I never
really let anybody I don't really tell
anybody what I'm gonna do one of them
was uh I gave the first Emmy to reality
TV
and one of them was uh Survivor and I
said go to East Los in the middle of the
night and be asking for it to find an
address you want to be a Survivor and
then I said Extreme Makeover where they
take someone who's ugly in an hour
they're beautiful I said isn't that what
a 12-pack does
and there were some great ones man and
and the the Monday of the next day they
quoted one of them in the LA Times and
they just got a a great review but while
they were while we were doing the show
they came down the aisle at The Shrine
to get me and when I got up and got up
and I said oh no no no you you stay here
what I'm going with you no no no no no
you burned your backstage pass yesterday
you don't think it's this shit's funny
why would I want you with me back there
so you stay here
and you know yeah you can't have anybody
I don't know if it's that way I I I
think I've been around enough musicians
that when you say to somebody listen to
this
and they don't get it
how does that make you guys how does it
make you guys feel if somebody says I I
don't know dude is that yeah you got you
got to keep on pushing forward you you
know like do you get hurt you get hurt
or is it just a because it's a process I
mean nothing's done but say hey I want
you to listen to this I keep an open
perspective as to what what is your
perspective thinking of this you know
and I'm like okay let me check that out
but you wouldn't let us listen to it
would you
yeah you know what that's all right you
know you guys you guys know music you
know what I'm saying in anyone's
perspective because the more everyone's
gonna hear it so that maybe it opens up
an idea over here or maybe it doesn't
but you can make that decision and be
like nah I could never discourage
anybody from what they're working on and
I I wouldn't have the intestinal
afforder to say you know what that's not
my style or it doesn't know anything you
told Richard Ramirez you couldn't kill
anything [ __ ] yeah I told him and he
didn't
and he didn't and so I I would nothing
but encouragement and that would be
devastating somebody you know for people
to come up and tell a lot of people do
it though yeah
I give you my kid they're like can I
give you my opinion or do you want it or
I'm like sure sure you know yeah with me
it's like I can take constructive
criticism from people that I know
critic what's the difference of
constructive criticism and criticism
okay it's like somebody that I might
respect that might be in the same thing
I do that says something to me about the
song as opposed to somebody online
that's just being an [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] I don't even know yeah exactly
that's what I mean I can never yeah I'm
not a professional musician I'm not a
Critic so there's no way I could ever
say anything bad to anybody that's in
the in the business yeah [ __ ]
you got banned from Instagram yeah thank
you yeah and I had one of those I at the
same time I got hacked on Facebook same
time then I got kicked off Instagram and
and I swear idle Instagram if you're
listening I don't [ __ ] around on
Instagram no vulgarity no political no
sexual nothing and I have no idea
because all they do is they said I
thought it was like I see on Facebook
these people come on 30 days in jail you
know 30 days I thought it was a 30 day
thing okay you can no it was a you know
I violated their terms and conditions
the agreement or something and I am
[ __ ] around so all I can think of is
somebody you didn't send nudes did you
because no no no no no that one picture
of me and a thong I
think that was that bad
come on in boys red that's right
boys.com so I don't so I don't know you
know what what they did why they threw
me off and I had one of those little
things on there saying that was the real
deal you know and so yeah [ __ ] your real
deal
and then okay so so uh um Elton John
who's who's calling it he's going to
wrap it up
um I think he's got three dates at
um right here at Dodger Stadium so so
with him and Bernie topping like Elton
John does the right lyrics he writes
music right so what however he met
Bernie toppen who writes the lyrics only
when they were in in his show he says
that they never wrote a song in the same
room that Bernie would be in one room
and out there being the other one and he
would say I got something for you so he
gives them the sheet of music to your
song you know the first hit that he had
and Elton John reads it
and he tells them our lives are never
going to be the same
because of of what the words were and
and when you've had hits
has a song surprise have you been
surprised either way by something that
is like oh I know people are gonna love
this
it's it's it's that good
yeah you know I think you never know you
know I think you just got to put things
out there no you know write as many as
you can and put as many out as you can
you just you know you never know what's
gonna light a fire and why it lit a fire
how many you know could you get
something into you know maybe this
marketing you know campaign where you
know so many people saw it and it just
lit fire and then that that's what
spread it amongst everywhere else you
never know you know I mean so you got
some great songs that no one no one
hears and they're just sitting there you
know it's because you know especially
these days you've got some something
like you know uh you know a hundred
thousand songs man you know going up
like the days
every day you wake up seventy thousand
[ __ ] pumped out of stuff no
[ __ ] everybody and their mother thinks
they can write a song now and they're
just pumping out there that's insane
it's overwhelming yeah it's crazy it
doesn't mean it's all you know I didn't
know it was that I didn't know that yeah
it's a crazy amount so how to cut
through the noise yeah that's a whole
nother and then and then um so you were
in San Antonio right uh so
that's another different kind of music
right I mean you you the names that you
that I saw that you like they're Rock
guys right yeah who do you like the um
rock guitarist I mean you like you love
rock oh yeah I'm that yeah that's my my
love I started out in like Judas Priest
Ozzy Osbourne Van Halen Motley Crue AC
DC that kind of stuff yeah
um but at the same time I was more
well-rounded than a lot of my rocker
friends because I I never turned my back
to classical guitar or even Tejano music
you know and that which ended up leading
me to the Selena you know era though
being in her band and playing all that
you know and then Abe who's who's a uh
her brother you know I learned so much
from him too I mean he worked really
hard at uh creating all those hits
yeah yeah it was a lot of work like I
was happy to just play guitar in that
band because everybody was so good at
what they did so it was like my dream
job it was before I had did when you
know when she passed I had to figure out
was I going to stick to music or in what
capacity how was I going to do it you
know and then I ended up making my own
band and going the rock route and we
want we want some awards and got a
Grammy and it's just I've just continued
going down that road yeah you want to
grab him congratulations yeah man thank
you sir congratulations I always tell
anybody that I've met I've met a lot of
athletes you know and and even guys that
playing golf tournaments that were
champions of other eras
uh if I see him then you say uh once a
champion always a champion and those
dudes appreciate that because yeah it's
virtually impossible to have that happen
so when it does happen it's just to say
oh you know I want to grab me it's quite
an accomplishment anybody that at the
time you were the [ __ ] and anybody
that wins one is congratulations
absolutely thank you champion thank you
but but
um we're gonna get after one together
you know we submitted this last year
um we didn't you know get a nomination
we're pushing ahead and I think the song
is an amazing song uh you know we're
going to keep on pushing that song
forward anybody out there is watching
please you know go go to Spotify or
iTunes and and streams don't don't say
it so fast eh you know yeah
people understand anybody out there
right now uh you know go to Spotify and
listen to pushing ahead by Chris Perez
uh you know but we're gonna go after
next year we have a couple of other
releases that we're going to do and
really go after you know the Grammy's uh
you know English Grammy Latin Grammy now
when you talk about malas palabra's
records yes yes malas palabas records so
you know we started malas Palace records
last year and uh you know we're um uh we
were just released you know Chris is
single this year we've got uh you know
more artists coming out uh you know next
year we've got Alexis grullion
from mdo menudo with a song that Chris
actually played guitar on uh called
muhed that's going to drop on on July
24th uh we've got some reggaeton music
coming over from from Miami with uh
Peter Amaro oh yeah you know yeah I mean
and the music is banging and so we're
gonna hit both sides English and Spanish
um and and we're gonna hit the ground
running next year you know this year we
you know tested the waters a bit and we
have a relationship with United Masters
uh you know um and uh you know I think
John for helping bring that relationship
to the table
um but you know uh you know uh Caesar
from United Masters is uh uh is our our
rep and you know he's an amazing guy and
helping us out and putting out all the
organization and details we call them
the ninja you know Cesar Sanchez from
United Masters you know
um right now they're United Masters is
releasing uh the the FIFA compilation
um two of their Independent Artists just
got nominated for Grammys
um and uh you know they're they're
really um as a distributor uh record
distributor they're really you know the
top of their game we have a
collaboration with apple and uh they're
pitching our music
um and uh their team's really excited we
have the first malas palabdas records is
the first record label deal with United
Masters That's History by the way
they've never done that before it's also
the congratulations under their umbrella
and by the way just to touch and their
business partners with us Steve Stout I
don't know I mean these Ballers like
LeBron James he's that guy yeah he owns
United Masters
he's looking at it they just started the
whole Latin division so they're looking
to really put a lot of effort and
momentum into the that division yeah
next year so I think we're catching yeah
they're excited to work with you with us
absolutely and uh yeah yeah we're gonna
hit the ground running next year it's
going to be big yeah and also um I did a
movie with Snoop called underdogs in
Atlanta yeah
so we will also also record with Death
Row Records I'm going to do a comedy
album and I'm gonna have it released
co-partnered with Manos palabas and
death row that's badass combo yeah yes
I said yeah man he's like [ __ ] I never
[ __ ] thought of that [ __ ] yep I said
yeah yeah all of it's all connected man
you know Bobby D yeah and then still
gave me a good friend uh Death Row
Records chain which I don't wear in
public because I don't want to die
gave it to me and I'm only gonna wear it
to them I thought that who it really
belongs to comes and gets him from me
yeah yeah but but uh yeah I mean all of
those things like
music is like there's no if somebody's
doing it on whatever level it just
benefits everybody even if it's a kid in
the back room of his of his
grandmother's house trying to picking up
saving money to play a guitar that is
picking out a guitar and then frustrated
and you know when you don't quit it
leads to things I mean all the times
that you guys said [ __ ] this man it's
just impossible
yeah I mean there's there's times you
know like like John was mentioning
earlier so many people are releasing so
much music on a daily basis that it can
it can feel overwhelming sometimes you
know but um at the same time I mean
where I'm at right now I feel lucky and
I've been
recently the last couple of months in a
really creative space and I got Bible
here in the studio with me that uh you
know he he helps me out a lot so explain
how explain Robert Gomez yeah okay so
babo and I have been friends for about
20 maybe wow about 20 years so he was in
the in the in the Cumbia Kings with me
with AB with the All-Stars with AV and
then we just come over here Governor so
you can see you the people that were
fans
but yeah right so so yeah all right
and and how did uh and musically how did
you how did you find music how did it
find you funny enough my sister she was
a singer and she got signed to Abraham
Abe's Dad yep and um so I just met I was
starting to try to produce music for my
sister Amy just heard music in the in
one of the studios there and so he's
like wait what is that came out of the
room and so then long story short I
ended up working with ab and producing
like a lot of the kumiki stuff yeah yeah
a lot of other big hits so so Abraham
the father is is musical too right yeah
he he plays music yeah he loves music
yeah he's plenty of times a lot of
people don't know but he actually can
play guitar too pretty good I mean there
was times we'd be in the tour bus and
he'd start playing I'm like whoa what
did you just do you know what this is
you know like it's nothing but I I
learned something from everybody but you
know I I met him we went I was in Corpus
Corpus and he was there and he he gave
me a tour of a studio there and he goes
back to like the 50s man right I don't
think anybody knows that uh Abraham
Quintanilla has a deep rooted loves
music can play music understands it can
tell you uh all the Motown all of that
stuff recorded stuff and I mean that's
why whenever I meet somebody that is
talented in something I would say well
who in your family had it because I
think that it's it's handed down
uh in in in family if if you if you
choose to use it or not you know some
people prefer not to you know
um but it's it's something in the
genealogy of a person you know yeah for
sure there's a pedigree yeah sure so so
you guys connected and you said you know
let's you just yeah well it was kind of
a gradual thing but I think
well my point is having somebody like
Bobble in the studio it's like you were
mentioning Eddie going in and turning
everything on and he's the one I imagine
him doing everything yeah he does yeah
you know what I mean so with somebody
like Bobble he's just and plus it's
almost like like a marriage kind of
thing where where I'll play something
and he knows right away if I'm doing my
my potential wow man that's crazy yeah
so um that takes a lot of the pressure
off you know what I mean and it just
kind of allows you to go in and
um once it's been created the song to go
in and record the best you can right
guys I mean it's a lot of history you
know like I record Chris recorded on all
the Kumi King albums and so I was the
engineer helped maybe produce all that
stuff so whenever Chris came to record
he was basically working with me so I
got to record him and know how he works
back in the day you know when I was
younger I took off lived in Miami worked
in Spain for many years
um and then recently came back to to
Texas and that's when we but what took
you what took you to Spain uh music yeah
to go produce I was working with the
pretty heavy hitter producer in the
Latin industry his name is rayito and he
invited me out there to go work out
there same thing Miami I mean Miami
there's a the Latin industry is all out
there so just in the studios over there
you meet everybody produced like like uh
Ricky Martin like Ricky Martin
it's a lot of people
Ricky Martin Shakira
um yeah so so you guys are maybe a
little bit too young I would say maybe
you remember
um when Ricky Martin performed at the
Grammys did he do la Vida Loca at the
Grand Museum
oh yeah I think it was wasn't it the
soccer tune yeah yeah it came down the
aisle and yeah yeah so
Ricky Martin did the Grammys
uh and and came down the aisle with
drums and all the the Latin was louder
more instruments and the next day he was
a [ __ ] star man like the next day
boom he's crazy how fast that happened
oh man [ __ ] overnight yeah that was
legit and I mean it it it I think
America thought that
this music that they create here was
World music it's not it's not music of
the world like you know Latin like
Carlos says African-American interests
and and African music and all that is
the war is the work music of the world
not not what we do here I think Ricky
gave gave it that flavor that people
could respond to you know I was watching
uh uh thing on Los Lobos and they were
playing La Bamba from the 80s and people
were dancing together and you know
unfortunately the way that the climate
is right now I don't think that that
would be the case today
that that they're at a plane outside of
the festival and everybody of all
different heritages are dancing together
I don't see that they played for my
brother-in-law's wedding in the 70s they
were just new they still had a heart
player instead of yeah they were just
starting out yeah but I mean it can it
can
I mean the sense memory of music of of
hearing a song and where it takes you or
also I don't think those guys that are
creating reasons or that's the way of
the world or you know uh all the songs
that people hear and they go man I
remember where I was like you have to
have
I don't think you can intend to write a
song like that it just becomes that song
right like it just becomes a hit and it
starts to mean things to people and then
in in its age that every time you hear
it you you just it takes you back to
that time man yeah yeah there's I mean I
guess everybody's different because I
remember a b every like his aim and and
the way he worked he wanted every song
that we recorded to be a hit like he he
really wanted it to you know so and not
all of them were but a a big majority of
them were you know and the numbers that
they hit you know when people used to
buy records right you they would you
know the spins on the radio I mean it
was just amazing did you play at the
Astrodome in that big show yes how many
people were there like
yeah I thought that was well the
Astrodome I don't know and then Reliant
uh that big other big one
oh yeah you're not wrong Astrodome
versus Reliant that was but Astrodome
was a time when
that was the biggest
like you know at that at that time those
you know whoever no Latin artist [ __ ]
Ricky Jones or they couldn't you know
they couldn't pull 70 000 yeah we were
the she was the first to do it and I
mean that was that last they call it the
last concert right
um but it wasn't technically the last
one it was it was pretty close
um but just when you play in a place
like that you know when you're in on
that stage and there's nobody around you
on the floor but they're all over there
it's just it's kind of a surreal
experience you know you kind of hear
them but you don't until you stop the
song or whatever but
um to see all those people there you
know and then again when they were
recreating it for the movie when they
were filming the Selena movie Gregory
Nava uh the director they booked the
Alamo Dome which is bigger than right
um the Astrodome they did the Alamo Dome
in San Antonio and just her fans
and it wasn't even Celine it was it was
Jennifer playing Selena but I mean they
showed up even more people showed up to
that yeah
yeah it's crazy so so you know uh in his
in music history
The Beatles did Shea Stadium The Beatles
did Candlestick Park
um um Elton John in 1976 did Dodger
Stadium it was rare that uh an artist
would be able to do a place that big a
stadium so again Like A Champion for you
guys to be able to do that with somebody
that wasn't that was
that just had such a incredible
support from the music just connected
and everything connected you know those
guys were world renowned you know you're
going to pull that but when somebody is
from an area that and it's just starting
like the flower is just starting to come
and Bloom that you you draw 65 000
people to the Astrodome to a show
it appeared that there was an evolution
of Latinos coming out we're here to
support you yeah it was an evolution
that started everything going so you
know [ __ ] Latin is the way they are
if they had 60 000 people imagine how
many people wanted to go right but they
were like
I've got the baby this weekend but you
know all the people that want to go that
that didn't go you know and uh I mean
amazing man in in music that uh that
that all of that like you guys saw all
of those things in in uh in the things
that you you know also I admire you for
uh
uh you your story is very private you
know and and and when other people are
out there and they do things on Netflix
or whatever
um I don't assume that that would be
your your story or what you saw because
it's very private you know somebody can
interpret uh what somebody was feeling
uh yeah but I I would say that those
things that are out there I think was
the the the
um the one from um Netflix yeah the
series is that it's why I didn't really
have much to do with that no um so why
don't they they don't ask you because
well I mean they don't want the oh
[ __ ] he said something up now from
from what I understand it I mean look we
all have our own perspective right right
um so that's their perspective that's
how they remember it and I thought you
know somebody come up to me one time and
they said uh the part of there's a part
in the series where we had eloped right
and there's the movie version of it
which is spot on by the way and then
there's the series version which is far
off but what people don't understand is
that it's not that it's like I'm
the way everything happened I'm thinking
that's what she how she told them it
went down so that's their you know
that's how they put it in the series but
um and when it came down but you know
nobody was in the room with us when we
were talking about it and just and had
decided so I I mean they had to get that
from me from the for the movie you know
so that well you know that's also also
you know uh something respectfully that
you're the closest person to her and she
was a closer person to you yeah and that
everybody's interpretation is
Generations from the truth like like
when you're in and it's just you and her
or you guys together having those
conversations that you know we had that
with our people that were close to us
but whatever somebody would interpret
that to be is not going to be anywhere
near the reality of what that situation
is yeah and I admire you for not
not for for keeping all of those things
just for yourself man yeah I mean they
belong well there's a lot yeah there's a
lot of stuff that I choose to keep to
myself only because only because I mean
those are my memories those that's
that's just for me yes you know and it's
not because there's some dark shady [ __ ]
that nobody's saying whatever it's just
those are mine you know yeah so it's
like
you know to this day there will be times
that you know because I have a lot of
our stuff you know and it's like the the
love letters and things like that that
you know every now and again I'm just
compelled to go open up the stuff and
just read you know read it again and it
it it actually nowadays helps me you
know at certain times if I need it
because
you know I mean she's not here to right
to help me out you know and and we used
to help each other out a lot so reading
those letters and cards and things like
that kind of
um
bring me back man I I don't even really
know man other than just to say that God
bless you man because I can't imagine
anything more difficult in your in a
world of somebody that's a human that
has to deal with anything yeah like this
man yeah you know it's tough I mean
we've all felt the majority of us have
felt massive loss in our life of
somebody that we love right but imagine
um
having to live a life where
you it's constantly like brought up
right you know what I mean and you have
no control over the average person bro
you have no level it never feels good
but it was like a whole nother left
right like if I choose to go read those
letters and those cards I'm choosing to
do it right but if you're out and about
somewhere and you know there's still
certain people that are like I'm so
sorry you know and it's cool I get it
but
um it's been it's been 25 years and I
feel like the the perspective has
shifted into a super positive thing for
me you know from her fans and just the
people in general now they see me as not
just El View though you know we all
understand the feelings of loss and
having to go through it but with time
people's perspective has thankfully
changed you know I think social media
has a lot to do with that too because
our our personality can come across if
you're
if you're being honest you know what I
mean and you're in I believe in the
pilot of the show mine had a t-shirt on
oh oh man I think I saw that yeah I've
seen that it always we cleared it yeah I
wanted to she wanted to wear it and I
said absolutely went to Corpus we went
to the you know to the studio and she
wanted to wear it in a clear yeah I mean
you know and maybe people see it maybe
they don't but that's where our that's
where our heart you know our minds are
what did it say I watched this it was
Selena T-shirt oh awesome yeah with
their with it it had the face on your
name right yeah yeah
yeah I saw that
um
but yeah you know as time has gone on
um
people kind of see me now for who I
really am as well and I and I got
treated pretty pretty badly by the Press
when she passed because I mean that's
the story everybody wanted was what's
her husband up to and and so I'm here
working on music and winning the Grammy
and whatever but then every interview
they would show they would leave all
that stuff out and just show the other
stuff and slow the footage down and it
was just an uphill battle for a really
long time but also also
um
things that were said to you by members
of the family that were that were really
awful things to say when they you know I
think when they were when they finally
relationship I think Abraham wasn't kind
to you yeah you know uh but you know
protect whatever a father would be of
his daughter naturally you know I don't
think his intention at that time you
couldn't tell predict the future but
things that were said to you
that
uh that you survived man yeah well I
mean it's like one of those things uh
leading with love you know and if I I
really did and I still do love the man
and I love uh the Quintanilla family
um and so I never really
I get hurt but I never if it makes any
sense I never took it to you you know
like hey I get it you know and as there
was a part of me that was sorry
you know for being going behind his back
and for both of us you know but it was
the only way we could [ __ ] Romeo and
Juliet man it's like you know when you
love somebody man and there's no Gil you
know I thought I used to wear the hot
dog stand you to go over there yeah yeah
I I tell you my mother my swag and I
hated oh yeah she hated me really yeah
well if I were visiting before I went
when I went to ask for her hand and my
wife's hand and mirror she got up and
walked out on me yeah you know and my
swagner just said hey you come back
tomorrow we'll do this again if she
walks out go get married in Vegas and
that's not what I wanted right so now
we're here I get married my wife's ex
because her cousin was in our wedding
and they were compared my wife's ex
showed up at the wedding dance sat with
my swagner and then told her to pass on
a message
tell her I don't care how many kids she
has how long it takes I'll always be
waiting for her yeah and my and my swag
and I did because my swag and I loved
him because he used to buy her roses she
didn't know he was a dealer you know she
used to buy him he bought her Rose and
he treated her nice so I was a mokoso
you know she didn't she didn't think I'd
amount to [ __ ] my wife was three years
older than I was so this was it was I
get married now I'm the only guy in the
family
foreign
I'm decent now we've been married so
many years my father-in-law passed away
my sweater was 90 years old then she
moved into my house and I took care of
her I told my wife I said yeah I gotta
put her in a home bring her here and
we'll take care of her yeah so we did so
from
hating me and kicking me out then she I
couldn't even I couldn't go in her house
yeah so from that I told my son I said
look at she's going to live in her house
now we're helping her out get her up to
her bed so that it didn't matter at all
turned around in the end yeah she
finally did accept me but also what's
right for you know what's right for each
other doesn't really matter who's in who
else is peripheral of parents or
whatever you know yeah yeah I mean there
comes a there was a point you know when
we we talked about it she and I and it
was like this is the only way you know
what I mean otherwise if if we do what
you want to do you know if like if I go
and let Abraham know what's up it's not
there's gonna be over you know what I
mean it's not gonna work
um
you know but having said all that I had
done some
we were friends for a long time before
yeah Celine and I were friends a long
time before so
um and I was a young dumb teenage boy
you know 18 19 years old and just doing
but I think it's beautiful like that I
mean you are I mean you're not expected
at that age to be anything but that
you're a music guy a guitar you love
rock at that time that's that's what it
is man that's what it is I mean that's a
young dumb and full of [ __ ] that's it
though
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we'll have your 1190
S no no no but I mean you know that's
all that's expected that's all that's
expected of
um of anybody man it's like you you
can't expect to be 28 when you're 18 17.
you're in that stuff and then and nobody
even thought about that we're now
[ __ ] kids think about the future and
[ __ ] let me just think about that day
what are you gonna do next what not even
[ __ ] this in that moment yeah that's
what we lose with phones and all the
other actions that we have is we lose
the [ __ ] moment where you're in the
moment right and somebody's in that
place when you see your friends and the
sun's going down and you're like hey
I'll [ __ ] see you tomorrow and you
that's that's it no selfie no [ __ ]
and you see your friend walk off you
know like [ __ ] that's that's a good day
that was a good day that was it yeah
exactly so you know you have that song
for the Raiders I think this year is not
the one to release that song well you
know what I thought a lot about that you
know what we're talking about is we have
a we have a song you know that we're
gonna release you know under Mata
palabras and it's called wind City
it's not really what's happening right
now
but I'm a Raider fan for life yeah you
know and like this is just my passion
for the Raiders you know I I I I love
the Raiders and we and George is a
greater fan for life you know the thing
is is I'm talking to the black hole
George right now yeah the fan club yep
beautiful you know and uh there's an
opportunity to perform the song uh when
we play the the ramps you know over in
in Vegas I think uh you know in a couple
weeks
um for the black hole I think the Rams
are gonna talk about that Chippendales
first
when they land in Vegas all the players
said can we stop at Chippendales first
you know before we go to the hotel
we need any Edge we can get right now
hey so so but doesn't matter I love the
right turn around we're not so I grew up
in La 70s Roman Gabriel never that's one
of one of the guys I always want to meet
that I never met
um
they leave town and all of us are deal
with abandonment issues you know I was a
Rams fan not for more Lakers but then
you know the Rams are there they leave
the Raiders moved to LA yeah and the
first game
in the same calendar year
the Rams are in Anaheim they walk out of
the tunnel of the Coliseum booze wow
[ __ ] Boo the Raiders come out they've
never played a snap in the Coliseum
everybody's like yeah because they left
so 25 years no football in LA and then
the Rams come back and they said are you
a son said I'm a Raider person I mean
imagine that your father left not a
[ __ ] word from him for 25 years
[ __ ] rolls back into town hey
Miko I'm back [ __ ] you I'm with my
stepdad over here they already won a
championship in L.A so now you'll be the
second La team to win a championship
they already won a championship you know
and on Monday Night Football they play
the Chargers and there were all these
cholitos there on a Monday night
they're like [ __ ] Charles they were
trying to get on TV so they're all
holding the this [ __ ] sheet and it
was spray paint writers you know MFL I
think they put [ __ ] football night
they put Monday football night they put
the [ __ ] [ __ ] backwards you know
Monday football nine not in that you
know and uh they're holding it up right
here with a [ __ ] cholos [ __ ] be
quiet they get on TV and then we if they
were sitting like two rows behind us and
the sheet said in small type property of
the Los Angeles County Jail
[Laughter]
look what it says on the sheet it said
property of L.A county jail and and
you're just like that's one of the most
beautiful [ __ ] things I've ever seen
that these mothers were like trying to
get on TV when the Rams left town okay
when they were they were here
Chuck Knox I believe was their coach at
the time when they were leaving
they had a dinner at Steven's Steakhouse
oh okay
cop one of the guy cop pulls one of the
guys over everything and the guy he
loaded he's one of the football players
so he pulls over and knocks out I want
to say it was Knox whoever the coach
yeah so so he he pulled over and he says
sir I'm I'm sorry what happened Chuck
Knox you know this just went out and he
says it's okay you know he says hey we
have somebody here we'll drive him home
you know not a problem we won't drive
and so he said okay just make sure he's
he's not going to drive no biggie he'll
leave the car here he says what's your
name he said no no you don't need money
he said no no I want to send you I want
to send you season tickets
he says no no no you really don't and
the guy looks he's okay I got your name
right here because I'm going to call the
Station he says thank you I'll never
forget this
the next morning the May and in the
paper times announcing Rams leaving La
that was her going away dinner oh yeah
and he didn't want anything but I mean
he made I'm gonna take care of you and
they were leaving well
um what what uh where does rap uh stand
in music like because you know it's a
new form right right uh from the early
80s you know Sugar Hill Gang and all
that and through the 90s uh of it uh
that was more you know very different
um what did you go how did you guys feel
about rapping your first when it first
came out it I I didn't listen to it you
know what I mean but as time went on
um I actually listened to it quite a bit
now you know Jay-Z this poetry yeah
right it's more poetry than I think
um
rock music is rock music you know
because people wrote it off for a lot of
years man and my come up was with this
guy named Rob Van Winkle better known as
Vanessa yes for nine years so I was in
that when the guy was blowing were you
at Vanilla Ice when he did Arsenio I did
our city man dude when he was pushing at
one point eight hundred thousand units a
week so don't tell me it wasn't
resonating with fans yeah that's when
there'd be no Kid Rock there'd be no
Eminem all that without ice first and
that that taught me a lot you know it
was a it was a pretty I mean it was an
innocent time of music like there wasn't
all the all the
um places to put music but remember that
time it was it was it was huge man
it's it's it's the number one genre
whether you love it or hate it yeah it
dominates man I I never listened to that
stuff
okay I'm stuck in the oldies they see
their oldies or comedy on my radio
and I went to your show now I met on the
show here
be real from Cypress Hill yeah
and so when I when I first saw him I
said what am I doing here you know the
cop that I was and here I am and the
guy's a very nice very articulate so be
real estate and Gil was sitting right
here and they were out there burning
smoking [ __ ] it looked like Cheech and
Chong movies
and and it was just us three and I said
if be real If he if he lights a joint
he's gonna leave
like and and he didn't but he we talked
for two hours he could not have been
smarter right no explaining yeah I was
so happy that I got the opportunity to
meet him you know don't judge a book by
its cover the guy was from the south
side and then he was all tatted down he
said this guy's a hood rat he came in
very articulate very intelligent very
nice guy I felt like I really met a
friend that day and he's really good but
I had never listened yeah too by the way
you might as well call it a strawberry
yeah
I go to uh I go Listen to George my
family going with the Laugh Factory or
wherever you're at in Hollywood we go
there
and before anybody comes on they're
playing the music and man some music
players man this is bad this is good
stuff and my daughter says Dad that's be
real and I really liked it it was it was
good good stuff yeah man so yeah but
outside of you know like ice whatever
you perceive them to be in the public
eye he's not that guy behind the scenes
a sharp dude man he's an entrepreneur
he's smart he's smart on how he's always
stayed in yeah you know the public eye
and it's funny man because you know it's
like they play that song
all and people love it and then for some
reason it turns and then you're a joke
it's like how can you be he is the
master of what in Wonder that's all he's
ever done ever crazy and that's my whole
point I always say all you need is one
man I know it from the guy well you need
one to get started but if but if you
only have one at least you had one yeah
exactly I always say you know oh people
[ __ ] about one-hand wonders but
wouldn't you rather have like
you know had that hit than to have been
like a has been like never to have been
at all kinds well it never will be or
never will be exactly dude it's a tough
you know people that people that um like
I mean I think you can say for all of us
here is that there are other people out
there that have talent that somehow talk
themselves out of their own [ __ ] uh
path in life no that should that's not
for me everybody now why would I why
would I make it why why why would I even
try you know it's too hard but listen
Matt everything worthwhile is hard I
mean if it was easy then just everybody
would be living their best life sure
we'd all have gold and platinum records
on yeah and we'd all live in big houses
but you know
in in kids and in athletics where they
don't keep uh uh well don't keep score
anymore I think it hurts you know to
have a top you need a bottom to have a
winner you need somebody who didn't win
say loser not a loser per se but that's
just the reality of it when somebody's
holding a trophy and you're not up there
and you say [ __ ] wait till next year
now can a kid say wait till [ __ ] next
you're gonna get a trophy next year
anyway oh that's right never mind
is that it makes you want to [ __ ] be
better and if you if there's no scale
amen
what what is the motivation to be what's
going to ignite a kid to be in the car
and you drop the ball and you're like
[ __ ] it [ __ ] this [ __ ] it's like don't
worry about it nothing no [ __ ] yeah we
lost I dropped the [ __ ] bone we lost
it's like they'll go back and and do
something else amen and go back and win
and we're just creating a generation of
kids that will not be eight or nine or
ten when they're frustrated by by losing
out on something that they wanted so bad
in sports or whatever everybody's
jumping around each other and and you're
like [ __ ] man [ __ ] next year and and
when you do win that satisfaction but if
the if that never happens to kids
there's no yeah there's no [ __ ]
future and [ __ ] everybody would just be
they settle disconnected yeah they
settle for [ __ ] man and then you know a
little kid I saw a little Chicano kid
walking to school and he's walking with
his book bag he's walking looking at his
phone
yeah I [ __ ] honked you dropped this
full crack this [ __ ] screen man
you got his attention today but I mean
and wherever you go like like I mean
when I was in in 1988 I did the maxim uh
Playboy Girls of Rock and Roll I [ __ ]
hated it
and
sounds like a good time yeah because I I
was backstage all the nipples were here
but then but then you know this dude
this [ __ ] guy
I got heckled one night and then the guy
somebody said why don't you just tell
jokes and everybody clapped it's like
the 100 seat room oh [ __ ] and the
producer called me in my room and tried
to tell me how to do comedy
and I was this was 88 and when I hung up
the phone I said [ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] this [ __ ] ah and you know
you don't know what you're going to
become I just didn't know I wanted that
guy or anybody telling me how to do
comedy yeah
yeah good instrument yeah yeah I mean
sometimes you have to stick up for
yourself even if it might if nobody but
you know like I think it's part of the
whole Integrity conversation you know
and being real you know what I mean and
if that's how you feel
[ __ ] say it but isn't just a hater
somebody is just sitting around with
that that hasn't done anything too much
time on their hands that that sitting
around somewhere that is gonna fall this
is the only connection to anything
that's the only job is to hate cool and
they're typing [ __ ] yeah man you ain't
[ __ ] in their basement of their mom's
[ __ ] or whatever the [ __ ] I mean so
has asked how I felt about that social
media [ __ ] and I said I just laugh at it
somebody said you know Richard should be
alive you should be dead you piece of
[ __ ] really yeah and so I look at it and
I I won't answer them right I just laugh
I mean here I'm an old asaurus already
but I've got this gig and I'm doing this
I'm retired making money you you sit in
your ass don't do what a goddamn thing
you ain't got no [ __ ] job all you got
time to do is criticize other people
it's funny
it's a 24-hour [ __ ] criticism and
hate is a 24-hour job if you're all if
you look at I don't look at the there
was a dude that was giving me [ __ ]
because I don't do my own social media
but I don't have time or it's not my
thing
don't look at me because I ain't got no
social media right now
but you know but you know I'm gonna have
to look up what you posted to get banned
from Twitter bro like you're such a nice
job not Twitter not not Twitter
Instagram yeah Instagram and my son what
the hell he used to do all my stuff for
me and I give him a picture you know he
comes out my house right here put this
picture up there put this yeah I didn't
do nothing I don't I don't mess around
with it I I can only believe that
somebody tried to hack somebody hacked
me and did put something up there I'm
not interested so who do you think it
was Chef Boyardee
he makes Italian food give me somebody
you know so somebody makes a good blue
roll let's talk uh let's talk make of
guitarist what what guitars what guitars
do you like
um did I have a guitar with me when I
saw you inside yeah yeah you had the
black the white with the black stripe EV
honest you had it that wasn't when we
were in Vegas the other couple weeks ago
oh that's right you had that one there I
played that one oh yeah yeah those are
awesome I love I have a few of those but
if I had to pick one I'd probably go
with a Fender Strat you know
um
because the Fender Strat is uh Brewster
Bruce Springsteen plays offender Strat
right you you record an offender Strat
it's not a heavy it's not a heavy guitar
no I I
record with a bunch of different guitars
yeah um but live it's
99 yeah they're just lighter
um I can get more sounds out of them
yeah you know with the three pickups
that I use yeah yeah when I was a kid
the band that I played in he was lead
guitar players uh they were making
trying to Casters in it was brand new
yeah you know it was up there I mean
it's you know it's interesting man you
because you know when I would go to a
concert and I would see after a song
them change the guitar and you'd be like
well why were they you know change the
guitar because every Everything has a
different sound right I still say that
it has a different it has a different
sound of uh [ __ ] bad Haley when I
told Eddie I said hey you never changed
guitar he goes nah and everyone had a
tune it's like and he goes and in 79 he
goes I only had one yeah but but the one
he had man I mean it was the first ever
he he did a perfect you know hit dude
with we were talking about him and he
took imperfection and crew created a a
Perfection yeah the the body was a
second he told me you told me the whole
thing the neck didn't match the body was
a second yeah and he said he didn't know
anything about second had a knot in it
in the wood and he said how much are
those and he couldn't afford the one and
he goes the guy and they had a pile of
them stacked uh behind the counter he
goes these are seconds you know and it's
like well if that was a first and that
was a second I'll take one of those you
know yeah and the neck didn't fit you
know the neck was another neck Kramer
neck or uh yeah uh Gibson whatever they
didn't they didn't go together and then
he dipped the pickups and wax and he
said it was burning all kinds I mean he
destroyed he said he destroyed tons of
guitars to get the sound that he wanted
but through through trial and error this
guy created a sound that
that's his own sound yeah for sure and
and I mean he just just thought now you
now you can it's like somebody growing
up nowadays and wants to play guitar you
can just go buy a guitar that's
basically the same thing as what he he
created out of thin air now every but my
guitar the one that I my number one we
call it C1 that one is would not it
would not be what it is had he not done
what he did wow I didn't know that he
start yeah now nowadays you buy guitar
Fender shot with a humbucker and a
whammy bar and the Locking systems and
he came up with all that the [ __ ]
login system the the drop D yeah yeah he
came up with all that stuff so what's C1
what what guitar is that C1 is uh I love
that too by the way it's the C1 yeah the
Arctic it's an arctic white
um Fender Stratocaster it has a
humbucker two single coils a Floyd Rose
um and and it was it was the first
guitar I bought right around the time
that uh Celine and I got married so that
guitar is like on on all the big songs
that's the one that I used to record
that one and it's my it's it's a
security blanket of sorts you know just
I have to have it around me and like no
it's as funny as it might seem um you
know when flights get canceled due to
weather or whatever and I have my guitar
with me because I never check it
underneath
and I'm in the hotel room and I'm bummed
out I'm not gonna see my kids or I'm not
gonna you know I have my guitar and that
thing I I [ __ ] you not sometimes I'll
take it out of the gig bag and I'll just
put it in the bed next to me you know
and then uh just you know yeah man yeah
I think that's that great it's a lot it
says that says a lot like you know
people have Yorkies
I like it man I might not ever eat
[ __ ] menudo again
oh don't tell me I I went on it maybe
went to a restaurant and say a Mexican
restaurant on Sunday goes can I have
some mdo
empty yeah
I made the mistakes
I was flying to Chicago to do benefit
out there
and I told him his first time I was
taking a Midnight Special you know
whatever they call it a red eye a red
eye well I don't know that's the first
time I'd ever done this and he says oh
do you know what your levels are gonna
smell like in the morning
over the Midwest
but you know it takes it takes uh like
you know stand up you know there's a lot
of there's thousands of [ __ ]
comedians you know I don't worry about
any of them but there's as long as
there's people and kids and wherever
they are that want to be funny that want
to try to do something that you know
isn't virtually impossible the same
thing with music and singers and and and
artists of stuff that as long as they're
out there which they always will be but
also I think
whatever their initial driving and kids
are made different you know
um that the music industry or anything
creative benefits from people trying I
mean nobody's gonna make it then don't
try there was a guy that grew up Henry
Rodriguez That Grew Up near us and he
was a little overweight you know and he
would just carry the guitar by the neck
not in a case and call him hanky man he
had like a almost like a small strap
just an acoustic and he would go home
and practice every day and he wasn't one
of us he wasn't he didn't play sports or
anything he was a year older
and then when we were in 10th Grade he
was a senior in high school and he was
in a band and we went to go see him at a
backyard party in Granada Hills and that
[ __ ] was playing Dazed and
Confused with a bow and a Les Paul wow
and long Harry was he was slim he had
long hair in his face and he was going
like this pandan and we're like is that
[ __ ] hanky I mean in those five years
in those six years he turned himself
into a [ __ ] musician for you can
learn as you would say for you can learn
don't make fun of gordos eh no no yes
don't make fun of gordos
that size of Vietnam
[Laughter]
but he's a writer he's a writer but I
mean but I mean for us when I was
growing up and I saw at that time I
wanted to do I mean be a comedian for
whatever that didn't look beyond
anything but I saw that [ __ ]
when he was holding an acoustic guitar a
big one too like that you know and
walking home holding it without a case
to turning into that guy that was
playing with all the hair down and
people just were tripping out on him and
be like in whatever level of success he
ever had after that but that's a moment
that I will never forget I've seen
somebody that came from where I came
from that in six years was doing
something that was virtually right out
of The Song Remains the Same like yeah
man yeah tell them to call them call in
and see where he's at now
I should put it out there call me up I
feel bad if he died a long time
but but you know I grew up around dudes
that were funny and also that too like
if you grew up around people that are
Musical
you you know not somebody like oh I
don't I don't get it you know I I I got
you off into some other thing but
wherever the universe puts you you find
those people that are like you yeah and
that's why you say like this dude is you
guys been doing it for so long yeah a
lot of my friends growing up were
actually uh musicians you know so they
were actually ahead of me in their uh
ability to play guitar and that and
that's good too yeah I had I I would and
I didn't say anything to anybody I would
be in the room with them and they'd be
playing the songs that we would listen
to if there's Judas priests or Ozzy
whatever and I'd see where their fingers
were going I wouldn't say [ __ ] I go home
I take off the piece of [ __ ] when I had
on the wall I figured okay his finger
was here on the second fret it was the
first note of Crazy Train F sharp and so
I got the load and then that's how I
started like from square square one yeah
so you you were you could oh do the
other do the thing for him through the
the detective thing do the for these
guys see where they end up there's a
there's a way to detectives find out uh
oh no how somebody process information
not my my practice okay remember he's
had three pairs everybody trying to take
your tops off
okay
what's the first thing coming up your
mind I say what's the first thing that
pops up in your mind when you talk about
your grandma
chewing gum chewing gum yeah the the gum
in your purse always had uh because she
had Dentures your visual uh freedance
yes
[Applause]
what's the first thing that comes to
your mind when you talk about your dad
I didn't have one
he was absent what about your mom what's
the first thing comes about your mom man
Legend
and she took both roles
what's the friend that comes up to your
grandma
my grandma
yeah she made some bombing okay
he's a visual person
kinesthetic you process information
visually visually wow you process with
your heart with your feelings Scorpio
always been that way good point that
that's that that is
I don't know if it's visual or
kinesthetic or combination of both I
don't know if you see the menudo or
taste them into the field of love that
she's going yeah then you're kinesthetic
as well so that's what I do to find out
what kind of person you are when I'm
talking if I want to interview I want to
talk to you so I can gear my questions
around visual stuff stuff that's going
to touch your heart
get you to open up to talk to me
yeah
that's pretty smart
so what was the other one Visual and
visual kind of aesthetic and audio if
you hear if you hear somebody sit there
and say so you guys I could see my first
time we had three I could see my grandma
right now yelling oh come on yeah you're
an audio you're here okay so Audio
Visual and kind of studies so they're
breaking somebody down in the
interrogation they ask them and then
they can see how they control questions
and then you do it let's continue oh
yeah awesome well thank you guys for
coming in man this is awesome dude
absolutely
and this one time I thought y'all were
drinking energy drinks I just saw that
it's uh
lit I'm like wait a minute I'm feeling
pretty good yeah that's pretty good beer
I'm just honored I can't believe that
I'm here with yeah Legend is with George
obviously in the show and yeah I think
you're always allowing me to be part of
it I love you man you know a lot of
respect for you and you as well thank
you George
brother I admire you man
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my life is crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it is what it is
[Music]
don't worry
[Applause]
[Music]
they didn't realize
I used to mess around
[Music]